[Musik]
breaking news hierbei bild live sehen
sie jetzt das weltexklusive interview
von paul ronzheimer mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten wohl oder mirza lenski
fängt die somatische präsident theke
gegangen bevor es hier in case you today
hier us ursula von der leyen eine
presskonferenz ohne day three rockets
from
atos
origin kramer thorsten
pause für juni deliktes
conference center newspictures vom
konkurs des videos die credit suisse
pictures
ich war nicht mehr ich
kann nicht mehr weinen
moment
erschwerten die ersten tage
sehr schwer
ich hatte immer nasse augen
die toten kinder vor meinen augen dass
es unerträglich
ja die fakten von heute 50 menschen
starben über
100 menschen wurden verletzt
zwei raketen haben eingeschlagen auf ein
bahnhof shin grammatur ist
das ist eine tragödie
und mit albat vor dem krieg ich war in
grammatur
unsere streitkräfte haben da leute
verteidigt haben den flughafen
verteidigt
[Musik]
acht jahren
geführt
es ist uns gelungen
da kann das leben wieder zurück wir
haben sehr viel zeit und geld investiert
dieser stadt wieder aufzubauen
und dieser stadt das leben wieder zurück
zu schenken
und hier passieren die wieder die stadt
wurde wieder angegriffen und genau an
diesem tag hatte ich auch treffen jetzt
mit frau von der leyen
und mit anderen eu-vertretern
es ist unser kriegs leben
es war ein tragischer morgen heute
vor so einem wichtigen treffen
wir müssen aber weiter kämpfen
als mensch sie sagen sie können nicht
mehr weinen sie müssen weiter waren sie
müssen mit sich mit frau von der leyen
treffen was macht diese krieg mit ihnen
zu den blues
es ist nicht von vorteil
du wirst nicht zum besseren menschen
du kannst dich an diese opfer nicht
gewöhnen aber
irgendwie wird man haben wenn sie haben
also ganz ehrlich sagen
ja ich
fühle hats ja natürlich so russland
suchen zu russischen soldaten ja ich
habe keine geheimnisse
ich spüre dass wenn ich diese bilder vor
meinem auge und ziehen wenn ich die
vielen toten viele
ermordete kinder ohne beine oder arme
es
ist ja fürchterlich
ist als vater natürlich
an meine kinder und ich mir dass
die bilder
die kinder auf die welt kommen
wie es ist einen ein kind zu erziehen
und es gewachsene zu sehen
einmal
musste die wehr davon wird den kindern
schulabschluss hochzeit oder jugendweihe
für die eltern und dann denkst du auch
an die eltern
der toten kinder
deren eltern so was nie erleben werden
sie werden ihre kinder nicht aufwachsen
sehen die werden nicht keine feiern mehr
mit ihm
verbringen
diesen ort kampf und er fragt die
zukunft mit eigenen kindern geklaut
worden die haben alles sehen und
dann setzen sie sich mit frau von der
leyen an den tisch ärgern sie sich
manchmal über die europäische union über
die länder die ihnen die sie nicht genug
unterstützt ja natürlich
ich ärgere mich nicht gegen
norwegen usa persönlich größerer
unterstützt uns
aber ich ärgere mich mich über manche
politiker ärgern sie sich über olaf
scholz über unseren bundeskanzler
erst momente wo ich nicht verstanden
habe warum
warum warum
die menschen in balance wählen
wollen sie wirklich dann persönlich so
ein angriff ums leben
manchmal ja in die emotionen zuerst ja
ich bin so ein mensch
das sage immer so was ich denke so habe
ich ja auch vom kanzler chance gedacht
wie kann man von einem mann anzusprechen
wenn die eigene geschichte auch so
schwer
und trifft deutschland hat auch viele
flecken in der geschichte und so habe
ich auch früher gedacht
der kanzler eine
mittepartei sein konnte ich wollte dass
er
eine
deutschland
hat eine führende rolle in europa
ich wollte dass er als sie an die seite
der wahrheit nicht stellen und ich
wollte dass er sich schnell für die
seine entscheidet und dass er an unserer
seite
aber
meine emotionen lassen
aus deutschland es nicht spreche nicht
vom deutschen volk ja ich habe gesehen
wie von anfang an dass gottschalk uns
unterstützt
wie auch sie für uns gekämpft haben
jetzt bekomme ich auch die erste der
unter
politikern gesprochen haben was war das
schlimmste was sie hörten
das war nicht mit ihm
ja es war eine
schlechte situation
ja von einem führenden politiker der eu
ich will ich möchte nicht darüber reden
zeigen sie uns beweise dass es nicht
saniert wurde
welcher politiker ihnen gesagt
ich möchte nicht über
ein europäischer politiker der was sie
sagt
es sind sie uns über butscher sprechen
herr präsident wir
waren in butter wir haben sehr viele
untersuchungen dort gemacht wir haben
mit menschen gesprochen die
uns erzählt haben dass russen klare
informationen haben welche zivilisten
sie töten wollen
und welche nicht wissen sie
über diese listen
wissen sie auch dass russen wussten wen
sie töten wollen als sie nach butter kam
[Musik]
das kino in dieser woche seine und da
sehen sie
[Musik]
ja ich nein ich verfüge nicht über
solche informationen
einige menschen
auch uns erzählt dass die invasoren
wussten wen sie den siebten wollten aber
ich bin ja ein ehrlicher mensch
ich hatte ja keine beweise dafür und
auch keine lacht
sie haben
die bürgermeister und die aktivisten
der gemeinden umgebracht naja ihr stimmt
sie haben
aktivisten
aktivisten der ukraine
sie haben ja
sie sofort an einem platz wo gesammelt
und
dann auch verschleppt das jetzt
tatsächlich in butter passiert das weiß
ich nicht
das ist das was man uns in butter
erzählt hatte sie haben gesagt dass sie
verwandte haben in der armee und
deswegen kamen russische soldaten
ausgerechnet zu ihnen nicht woanders sie
haben gesagt sie wussten genau
auf saß pippo in big sieht ist also ich
weiß dass es viele menschen gibt in
großen städten in hessen also sie da
gibt es ängste
da gibt es menschen die die auch kämpfen
also viele menschen in der welt wundern
sich darüber wie viele features gibt es
noch eine ukraine kein mensch weiß kein
mensch weiß es weil wir momentan es
nicht wissen
wir wissen nicht was los ist im süden
unseres
landes
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt eine kleine ort des
zwischenfalls der kerze oder
im osten des landes
da manche und komplett vernichtet die zb
von der wahl
dieser stadt existiert nicht mehr
keine häuser so keine menschen
was wir davor
und hätte das gesehen und hätte gesehen
was in grammatik passierte es was in
butter passierte und dann kommt jemand
setze ich mir gegenüber und
sagt mir beziehungsweise ich sehe dass
man nach wie vor noch keine öl-embargo
eingeführt hat aber ursula sagte muir
da sie versuchen da sie sich bemühen
dass ich sehr viel diskutieren und das
ursel us-position einer klare ist eine
direkter ist und es gibt auch länder
aber wir wissen auch dass deutschland so
etwas nicht möchte dass deutschland kein
öl embargo möchte
also es gibt ein ko lemberger und
aber eine diskussion darüber war auch
eine sehr lange also es ist vor allem
deutsche schuld dass die deutsche
regierung so etwas blockiert
ja einige länder
deutschland gehört auch dazu sind gegen
öl und gas embargo
ich bin froh dass das fünfte aktion das
kohle und holz embargo enthält
[Musik]
ja und zwei länder darunter auch
deutschland
haben für übergangsphase von vier
monaten zu stimmen
ja das ist die wahrheit zu
olaf scholz sie haben doch keine vier
monate irland ist im krieg sie müssen
jetzt im osten kämpfen und sie sagen
ihnen warten
die schulter brauchst deutschland hat
nicht so einfach herr scholz hat auch
nicht so einfach
deutschland hat sehr viele inter
wirtschaftlichen interessen
in russland
kann herr scholz ist nicht so lange im
kanzleramt
ist nichts doch einfach
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit
machen können das machen was heißt es
was glauben sie was denken sie darüber
[Musik]
sie können ja nicht moderat
moderat ish die führenden politikern in
europa können ja nicht moderat seien
wieder russland
kleiner kann das verstehen
jeder politiker
eine position haben
die politiker
sollen an der seite der wahrheit schön
und ehrlich sein
soll führende rolle in europa übernehmen
der provokative frage
ja was
juli
strom
wird
spitzen-duo die schlichtung ist eine
entscheiden sind mehr stringer
ich möchte die usa und deutschland nicht
vergleichen
sind verschiedene welten
die wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit mit
russland ist irgendwie wichtig für
deutschland und auch weniger für und usa
oder die sind unabhängig von der von
wirtschaft russlands deswegen beiden ist
ja auch oft in seiner rhetorik nicht nur
auch eine chance sein also es gibt auch
verschiedene aussagen über
waffenlieferungen und wie das
funktioniert und wie viele waffen aus
europa und aus deutschland kommt
kommentiert er in die ukraine deutsche
regierung sagt dass viel geliefert wird
geheim sie wollen nicht darüber reden
was ist die wahrheit
die wahrheit liegt daran dass von anfang
an deutschland sehr vorsichtig gegenüber
der unterstützung der ukraine
war und ich spreche jetzt nicht vom
deutschen volk sondern von der deutschen
regierung
deutschland hat uns nicht mit waffen
unterstützt sie haben offen darüber
gesprochen
dürfen in deutschland hat auch
offen
darüber gesagt dass
die ja kein mitglied von nato sein
werden auch nicht mehr auch kein
eu-mitglied
saß aber
wenn wir ehrlich
jetzt die rhetorik deutschland hat sich
verändert
[Musik]
ja aber deutschland hat keine führende
rolle in europa deutschland ist
konservativ und kalt uns gegenüber aber
weißt du der zu als sich bewegt und ich
glaube dass wir schwer für mich zu hören
als deutsche es ist schwer für mich von
dir zu hören dass deutsche kalt sind
sind sie wirklich so kalt
deutsche oder ist es mehr die regierung
nein
ich bin ja auch ehrlich ich hab deutsche
auch gesehen auf einem der großen
deutsche plätze ich habe sie gesehen als
sie da in unserer unterstützung
aufgetreten sind am brandenburger tor ja
genau ja ich hab sie gesehen das waren
keine kalten menschen sie sind
aufrichtig sie haben uns aufrichtig
unterstützt deswegen wenig deutschland
gegenüber sehr sehr dankbar alle
politiker müssen einfach nur ein kleines
fenster aufmachen und ihre menschen sich
angucken und ich habe ihre gesichter
gesehen am ende unseres interviews
präsident müssen wir darüber sprechen
was in den kommenden wochen passiert
heute gab es diese diesen anschlag in
grammatik auf menschen die flüchten
wollten die weg wollten aus dem osten
sie sind ermordet von einer rakete
was ist denn putins ziel was will er
denn ich frage sie das immer und immer
wieder
seit einiger zeit aber heute was würden
sie sagen was ist ihre antwort
wissen sie wo das problem liegt
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher ob er
überhaupt begreift was passiert
wenn ich von china hätte der jeder über
jeden angriff auf unsere städte dörfer
und formiert werde
über
täglich in unserem land ich bin mir
sicher dass er überhaupt nicht weiß was
in wirklichkeit da abgeht er hat ein wie
viel gegeben und los wie viele
menschen sterben
in der wirklichkeit passiert
wie viele kinder wie viele menschen
dabei sterben wie viele häuser verletzt
zerstört werden oder
abgebrannt werden
das weiß er alles nicht und dieser
prozess selbst interessiert ihn nicht er
braucht ein ergebnis
er möchte an sein ziel kommen und wir
insel verteidigen unser land in den
letzten paar wochen haben sie
sich für gespräche mit putin
ausgesprochen könne sie jetzt mit
jemandem reden der verantwortlich ist
dafür was in butter basiertes und auch
für andere kriegsverbrechen
verantwortlich ist können sich hinsetzen
und reden mit jemand der
kriegsverbrecher ist
heute ich möchte unterschreiben heute
hat
die ukraine
keinen anderen ausweg
als sich am verhandlungstisch zu sitzen
aber
in russland hat kein anderer
macht diesen krieg zu stoppen nur er
allein entscheidet
man sich sehr wichtig endes
ja wir haben auch ein weg mit der
unterstützung von unseren verbündeten
langsam
zu beenden
[Musik]
wir verteidigen uns lang und kam ja
kämpfen wirklich
was würden sie machen wenn wladimir
putin sie anruft und sagt
lass uns treffen kommen morgen nach
moskau wahrscheinlich nicht nach moskau
sondern sagt ihnen lass uns treffen
lassen uns sprechen nachdem er sein
botschaft in caracas passiert es können
sie sich mit ihm hinsetzen und mit ihm
reden ihm in die augen gucken und mit
ihm verhandeln domo
creamy
wie eine vereinbarung gingen davon ab
wie viele städte oder dörfern
erobert wurde ja er ist davon überzeugt
dass diese sonder operation nach plan
läuft und
ich denke
irgendwie er hat auch weitere ideen oder
pläne naja das
interessiert ihn wirklich nicht er
brauchte ergebnis was ich schon gesagt
habe und ich und wir leiden in diesem
prozess und ich erlebe diese krieg
prozess wirklich
viele tote haben wir jeden tag
das habe ich auch zu
unserer verhandlungs zirkulation gesagt
[Musik]
wir wurden von der seite russland und
von der seite weißrussland angegriffen
und als unserer delegation in türkei in
der türkei qualifikation gesagt wenn so
eintreten zwischen zwei präsidenten
angeboten wird dann
ja ich treffe
es gibt ja viele spekulationen
dass putin bestimmte ziele erreichen
will bis zum 9
bis zur kapitulation der wehrmacht am 9
mai und das ist ja ein feiertag in
russland glauben sie dass er auch bis
zum 9 mai etwas erreichen will
man sagt so stehen dort ja dass russland
so polish auf symbolische daten
und die politik ist ja auch solche daten
feiern möchte
ich sehe da keinen
ich weiß auch nicht wie man damit
umgehen kann
wollen sie aber 15 tut weh so eine feier
mal
ist es eine ungesunde psyche
nicht
an dem oder anderen tag einzieht
nach deren meinung feiern möchten aber
das sollen sie ja noch erreichen wir
kämpfen weiter
ja mag sein dass es für dich ein sieg
ist und für die ganze andere welt ist
eine tragödie
ich weiß nicht
also wenn wir uns nächste woche
zb also wir erwarten nächste woche
schwere kämpfe
es kann es können dinge passieren was
wir noch nie gesehen haben wir sie lange
nicht gesehen haben was glauben sie
würde in den nächsten tagen und den
nächsten wochen in den bars und um das
herum passieren
verschwunden
na dann
es kann ein großer
krieg seien
in ein klick im kompass den die welt der
letzten jahrhunderte vielleicht nicht
gesehen hat
wir werden aber weiter verteilten und
wir werden weiter kämpfen bis zum ende
und er muss verstehen dass
davon natürlich auch die weiteren
verhandlungen abhängen
auch sogar die wahrscheinlich und der
weiteren reise wenn sie ihre augen
schließen wenn sie ihre augen heute
abend schließen uns versuchen zu
schlafen war sehen sie da
denn es geht ja nicht nur um heute also
ganz generell wenn sie ins bett gehen
und versuchen zu schlafen war sehen sie
das ist das stichwort
versuchen zu schlafen
was sich dann vom einen geschlossenen
augen also ich sehe eigentlich nichts
weil es sehr schwer ist einzuschlafen es
ist sehr schwer einzuschlafen ich rede
ich lese ich schaue
nachrichten
ich bewege mich von a nach b
ich ändere meine position also es ist
sehr sehr schwer einzuschlafen
deswegen kann ich mich eigentlich
gar nicht daran erinnert an den moment
wenn ich einschlafe
es gibt ein unterschied zwischen fotos
früher und nachdem sie in butter waren
wenn sie diese fotos vergleichen was
denken sie
also wenn sie zwei foto sich angucken
was löst es in ihnen aus die bilder vor
dem krieg und jetzt
sind zwei verschiedene
das musste passieren und es ist passiert
es ist zum vorteil für unser land
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ja aber
zu diesen menschen sich über das
gespräch bedanken ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen herr präsident ich hoffe sie
kriegen heute ein paar stunden schlaf
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute ich bedanke
mich
ja das war das weltexklusive interview
von paul ronzheimer mit ukraines
präsident selensky ein mann der sagt ich
weine nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr
weinen ein hoch